If you're a teenager considering entrepreneurship
as a career, and you're asking, "how can I
find a mentor to show me the way". Hang tight,
hang tight, before you spend thousands of
dollars on these online experts and gurus
that are going to change your life if you
buy their software, and watch these 42 steps.
It's completely going to revolutionize your
life.
Hang tight before you do that. I'm going to
explain to you why that is.
A few months back I did a video titled 14
Ways Teenage Entrepreneurs Can Make Money,
that, on YouTube got a few hundred thousand
views. And forget about the views. It brought
thousands of Snapchat messages that I had
to respond to. Hey, Pat, I'm 14 years old.
I want to be an entrepreneur. I love Valuetainment.
I just want to know how to get started. Hey,
Pat, I'm 16 years old. I'm thinking about
starting a business, what do I do? Hey Pat,
I'm 15. . . I got so many messages. And finally
I said, Listen. This one guy, multiple, Pat,
I'm about to have my mother pay for this guy
his name, $6,000 and he's going to help me
become a millionaire. What do you think? Should
I do it, or not? I'm saying yes, my mom's
saying no. What do you think?
I said, hang tight. Because here's the thing
you've got to be thinking about. The first
thing you've got to think about, if you want
to become an entrepreneur and get a mentor,
you need to know what level you're at. Let
me explain to you what I mean by what level
you're at. If you choose to become a body
builder, there's a personal trainer, based
out of Venice Beach, California. He works
at the gym of gyms. This is like the Gold's
Gym Arnold would go and work out at, back
in the day. I mean, this is the place Franco
Columbu, you know, Weider would send his boys
over there. This is the place to go to. And
Charles Glass is like God to body builders.
If he personal trains you, you are very lucky.
But he's two, three, four hundred dollars
an hour. So what if you say, "I'm 14 years
old and I'm thinking about lifting weights."
Do you need to go get Charles Glass? No. You
just need to get the basics about weight lifting
to see if it even sparks something in you.
To see if even something catches. And then
all of a sudden, you fall in love with body
building, then it's a whole different story.
Forget about it. Then you're eventually going
to get to his level. So the question I want
you to ask yourself is, what level of entrepreneurship
are you at right now, with the level of income.
Think about this here.
There are four tiers. Tier number one, you're
watching this, you're 14 years old, a teenager
thinking about becoming an entrepreneur, but
this is how much money you've made as an entrepreneur.
Zero dollars. You can find somebody right
now, that's making $3,000 a month, as a teenage
entrepreneur that can be a mentor to you.
Now what if you're saying, "Pat, I am making
$2,000 per month as a teenage entrepreneur.
What do I do with that?" Then you need to
find a level two, tier two , that's making
three to ten thousand dollars per month. And
see what that person can show you how to do.
What if you're saying, "But Pat, I'm making
$9,000 a month. Then you need a tier three,
$100,000 to a million.
Pat, I'm making $300,000 per year. Then maybe
you need a tier four, a million and up.
Now, watch this. What if you've never made
money, and you're saying, "Can this person
[tier 4] show me how to do things? This person's
going to speak certain language to you you're
not going to understand. It's like going to
a new country, trying to learn Portuguese.
You're not going to speak it. So this [tier
4] person's going to get frustrated. And you're
going to get frustrated, because he's expecting
you to speak his language at this level [tier
4], and you don't even know how to say, "book."
We got to first teach you how to say, "book."
That's what you've got to learn. And I know
as a 14-year-old, you want to become a billionaire
by 15, because right now, every single magazine
you watch, it says what? Now the youngest
billionaire is 23 years old! Now the youngest
billionaire is 19 years old! Now the youngest
billionaire is. . . there's so much of that
going on, that everybody's forgetting the
basic fundamentals of going back to, I need
to learn the basic steps to get there.
So now, having said this, you know what level
you're in, now let's go over here.
So what do you look for when you're looking
for a mentor? How do I find a mentor? The
biggest recommendation I can tell you, I talked
about this in another video, that I just want
to re-remind you. Any time you're choosing
a mentor, you've got to keep the TEA Theory
in mind. TEA Theory. What is the TEA Theory
when it comes down to mentors? T E A Theory.
T is theory, E is Experience, A is Application.
Let me explain.
There are mentors out there, who are very
good at teaching you theories, but they've
never done it. It's called "University Professors."
It's called, "College Professors." Here's
how you run a business. I'm sorry, Miss Jones,
have you ever ran a business before? I haven't,
but I've consulted many. No, have you ran
a business? I have not, but that's not the
point. I've read all the books. That's a theory.
Nothing wrong with it, but they're theory.
They're the lowest level of teachers to bring
you value. They still can bring you value,
but they're not the highest level.
Then you have experience. You know who's experienced?
Experience is somebody who you say, "Have
you ever ran a business Mr. Jones? All of
this stuff you write about in this book."
I never ran a business, but guess what? I
worked under Steve Jobs for six years. That's
a lot of value. That's experience. It wasn't
him, but he watched somebody who was doing
it, and they experienced being close to them.
Have you ever done real estate before? I never
have, but who were you? I was the assistant
for the #1 real estate agent in Beverly Hills
who sold $50 million of homes per year for
ten years in a row. Now that's money right
there.
That person can tell you so, what time did
they come in? What time did they leave? How
did they do? What did they do? How did he
treat his clients? Tell me the biggest. . . and
was there a time he almost went out of business?
That's the experience.
And the level three, highest one, is the actual
source. This is a person that actually, what
they're telling you they've done what worked
for them. So this is the entrepreneur that
who has their own theories, who has experience,
and who has applied his theories, his experience,
that's got him to where he's at. I call these
guys trifectas. You're looking for trifectas
as a mentor. And by the way, they're tough
to find. They're tough to find. Trifecta is
somebody like, if you were to say a Musk trifecta,
a Cuban trifecta. You go to certain people
who are running businesses, they're trifectas.
There's a lot of online YouTube videos who
are purely level one and level two. They're
not level three.
Now, some of them, because of the tens of
thousands of dollars people spent to buy their
courses, now they're investors. And they say,
"I'm an investor." And by the way, just to
call yourself an investor, just so everybody
knows, if I give Z here $5 to go buy gum at
Wal-Mart and sell it for $15, I am an investor.
FYI, anybody can call themselves, it's so
fascinating when people call themselves investors.
Anybody can call themselves an investor. I
can simply put money into a mutual fund, a
million dollars, ten million dollars, into
one of my mutual fund accounts and say I have
invested into 500 different Fortune 500 companies.
It's called start a mutual fund in an S&P
account and put a million dollars into it.
So again, do some due diligence on your own
to know what is a TEA theory and apply as
much as you can, try as much as you can to
get an application type of a mentor that's
trifecta.
Now having said that, so now, how do we find
a mentor? How do I get a mentor as a teenage
entrepreneur? Four levels.
Number one, a dead mentor. What is a dead
mentor? Steve Jobs is dead. Go study his content.
Go study anybody that worked with him. Go
study anybody that worked closely to him.
Go watch his interviews. Go watch every one
of his interviews. Go see how he answers.
Go see how he thinks. Go see how his enemies
said what they said about him. Why did his
enemies not like him? What did his enemies
say about him? What did people in Silicon
Valley say about him? Go study Rockefeller.
What happened to Rockefeller? What happened
with Rockefeller and Carnegie? What were the
fights about? What did Rockefeller do? He's
a dead mentor. Go study Franklin. Benjamin
Franklin is probably one of the least recognized
entrepreneurs to study. Go study how that
guy came up. Go study how we went to Europe
and negotiated deals. Go study his battles
with relatives. Go study Benjamin Franklin.
Dead mentor. You know who can go and be mentored
by Benjamin Franklin? That 13-year-old kid
that's watching right now from Nigeria. That
14-year-old kid - you, that's watching it
from Spain. You can go study Benjamin Franklin.
You can go study Jobs. You can go study Rockefeller.
They're all dead. A dead mentor. I would much
rather have you study those dead mentors than
pay $6,000 to an online guru that's going
to change your life. I would much rather have
you study some dead mentors.
Number two, an online mentor. Now what do
I mean by an online mentor? I'm not talking
an online mentor you pay. I'm talking an online
mentor that has content accessible to you.
Do not spend money, until you finally learn
how to do curls, dumb bells, basic chest,
then you need to learn how to do the cables
because you want to work your obliques. Then
you want to learn how to do shoulder presses
that you bend here because you want to hit
a certain spot on your shoulders. But at first,
just learn how to do shoulder presses.
There are many online mentors that can teach
you basics about marketing, all this other
stuff. Matter of fact, if you haven't watched
Valuetainment, my challenge to you would be
this. Watch all the Valuetainment videos.
And look what happens to you. It will typically
take you a couple of months to watch the whole
thing. Watch what happens. You won't speak
the same language. I have so many people,
every day I get hundreds of messages, every
single week, I have to say week. Every week
I get hundreds of messages that people say,
I watched this video, I grew my business from
$7,000 a month to $83,000 a month. I'm a teenage
entrepreneur, 13 years old, today I made $625
because of what was taught about in the video
14 ways teenage entrepreneurs make money.
Online mentors, they're out there. You can
find them. There's a lot of content to study.
Next, a local center of influence. So, for
instance, find out locally if there's somebody
that's running a local business, I don't know,
doing $500,000 a year, a liquor store, somebody
that's running a real estate shop, somebody
that's running a whatever it is. I remember
when I was coming up, I called a guy and I
told him, I said, Look, I went and interviewed
him for a job - he interviewed me for a job,
and I chose not to work there, but I was so
impressed by this guy. His name was Jamie.
I was so impressed by him, I kept his business
card, and I came back to him three months
later. And I said, Look, all I ask you, is
just to allow me to take you out to lunch
once a quarter. I don't want anything from
you. I'll promise you a few things. I'm going
to grow. I'm going to be successful. I'm going
to win in life. I'm going to work my butt
off. And eventually, I'm going to become so
successful that I will bring value to you
in any way possible, because I'm indebted
to you. And he saw the eyes, because eyes
can't lie. And eventually he said, You know
what? No problem. Took him up on the deal.
We'd go to this restaurant together on, I
think it was on Venice in Santa Monica. It
was called Bamboo. And we'd have this great,
I think it was Argentinian food. That was
our spot. We would go there. And he would
see me. Boom. And then one time I was speaking
at a high school that I was invited to. 600
kids were there. And he came. Then our relationship
grew to a whole different level. Then I spent
my birthday at his house. We were together,
talking all this stuff. He's doing very, very
well for himself. But it was a local center
of influence. And that's where I got started,
when I was 21 years old. That's where I got
started when I was 21 years old. Finding someone
locally that's successful.
Next, shadow a successful entrepreneur. What's
shadow a successful entrepreneur? If you can
get to this level, by the way, this doesn't
happen overnight, but if you can get to this
level, where you get in, sometimes you just
got to get in, you get in, and you got this
one guy worth 100 million bucks. He's worth
200 million bucks. He's worth 300 million
dollars, And he's locally he's working. If
you can be around that environment, and you
see, the most important thing to learn is
conflicts. That's what you want to learn.
You want to learn conflicts. You want to learn
negotiations. You want to learn the fights.
You want to learn the enemies. You want to
learn how do we handle this enemy. You want
to learn those types of things. You want to
be in the meeting and just listen to how dialogs
are being done. You want to study their mannerisms.
You want to know how they're brain is wired.
You want to know how to process certain issues.
You want to stay late and if their day to
get a 10-minute conversation, that's what
you're looking for when you're able to work
with a successful entrepreneur you can shadow
for a few minutes. When I had a chance to
do this, I didn't care what time it was. I'm
there because I just want to learn. All I'm
looking for is feed my mind. I just want to
see things I can do better. How is this guy
doing certain things that I can pick up for
myself.
So, with that being said, teenagers with the
aspiration of becoming an entrepreneur, which
I can tell you here, it's one of the craziest
decisions you'll make, but if you're serious,
and you've got it in your blood to become
an entrepreneur, and you're willing to improve
and learn, you do your part, that's one of
the best decisions you'll ever make.
The options, to do a quick recap, what tier
are you? Where are you at? And make sure you're
always going a tier ahead to learn from them,
because you speak the same language, if not
a little bit more than you. Find the TEA Theory,
trifecta entrepreneurs, and then find out
which one of these four mentors you can go
out there and learn from.
And with that being said, if you've got any
questions, you can snap me. But don't snap
me and say, Pat, can you mentor me? Because
I get that every day. Don't snap me and tell
me you want me to mentor you if you haven't
watched all the Valuetainment videos. First
things first. You've got to watch all the
Valuetainment videos. And the way I know,
is if you comment on every single one of them,
that you watch. I watch this and here's what
I got. I watched this and here's what I got.
Because I will test you. So, first things
first, you got any questions you can snap
me, on Snapchat, you see the image over here,
it's betdavid19. If you've got any questions
or thoughts, comment on the bottom. Do not
spend that money, before you follow this system.
If you've got friends that are about to spend
that money on an online mentor that $6,000,
or whatever the number is, share this video
with them.
And if you have not subscribed to the number
one how-to channel for entrepreneurs on YouTube,
please do so. And YouTube's got this new thing
here, I keep telling everybody about, click
right next to it. It's an alert button. What
happens is you become one of the first to
be notified every time a new Valuetainment
episode goes up on YouTube, so please subscribe.
Our goal is to get to a million subs before
2017. Just a year ago we were at 5,000 subs
or so. Right now we're at 155,000 subs, and
our plan is a year from now, December 31,
2017, to crack one million subs on YouTube.
And we need your help to get us to a million
subs.
There we go, Dennis, good catch. Again, comment
on the bottom with questions and thoughts.
Thanks for watching everybody, take care.
Bye, bye.